but I'm gonna come at a different angle
cool yeah we know two parent households
is the most optimal thing when you look
at the extremes most men know in jail
most men that sexual abusers etc etc
from uh single parent homes but one
thing I have found is that if you manage
to make it out the resilience you do
have from coming from a single person's
home if you do make out is different and
the only reason why I say this was when
I look at my brother he's completely
different to me in a sense of he grew up
with a dad
um all the things that I wanted to get
involved in he's he just thought it was
nonsense he thought Road was before I
thought Hood life whatever it is he
thought it was nonsense
but for me from for me mentally when
times get hard he struggles and I see a
lot of privileged kids who struggle like
from a young age I played Academy Sports
I played
um Semi-Pro rugby now and I was with all
the academies I was with a pro team and
a lot of them are privileged kids and
when times got hard they just crumbled
but the problem is is when I went back
to my old school to my whole dead
teacher I said thank you for not
expelling me and he said you know what
it is he said he saw something in me
that he didn't see in someone else and
he's like if you managed to make it out
of here
you'll be fine but I'm going out into
the world and you see with most
millionaires everyone thinks it's
generational wealth but 70 of
millionaires in the US are self-made so
if you do manage to make it out and you
get to that extreme I think it gives you
a different kind of mindset that you'll
be able to deal with it with the
hardships of life
absolutely no that's real that's real
and I again I relate to what you're
saying because I feel like
bruh the the obstacles the episodes you
go through yeah especially when you know
you haven't got no one to run to you're
not in school I'll get my dad to do it
bro I didn't have that bro it was me it
was on me bro like when I got bullied I
had to stand up for myself like when
things came to you on the road as it
does We're from south London things will
come to you even if you want to be a
choir boy it will come like you're gonna
say it and it does build character you
know what I'm saying like characters
built through adversity do you get what
I'm saying so you know it's just like
what you're saying like these you know
public school boys girls whatever you
know they probably haven't really had to
struggle they ain't going through eating
cereal with water that's an extreme I
didn't do that but that's an extreme you
know so when they do face hard times or
like a big bad wolf comes to them but
it's curtains but they're falling apart
in it you know what I'm saying so no I
definitely agree with uh relate to that
I wouldn't agree I relate to that but
obviously optimal you'd want a
two-parent fan family stability there
like to get what I'm saying it just it
just does so so much for a child
mentally and just in general for like
development you know what I'm saying
well Auntie what do you think about it
though I can't speak from my experience
I grew up two parents single parent
mothers are lazy this is lazy I'm sorry
I just gotta say they're lazy my mom
wasn't lazy right single parents
if you're a single parent because your
man's died or because he's abusive
something like that otherwise don't open
your legs and have a child and just go
on like that because as far as I'm
concerned my mum ended up a single
parent after being married no fault of
her own
but she never said anything bad about my
dad she left it all there for him and he
stepped up when he wanted to you know
that one of them ways if you behave
yourself I want to call your dad
and then one time I done something wrong
and he said he said why'd you do that I
said that's the only time that you come
you know and
after that I became a single parent and
it was better for me to become a single
parent than to be an abusive
relationship but I never said anything
bad about his dad he now found out what
a piece of doo doo his daddy is on his
own
but I was a lazy single parent know how
to do ties my son could fix a car and
strip her motor at the age of 13. he
knew what an engine looked like
and the single parents out there still
hear it the single parents out there now
they're just lazy they're lazy and it
ain't just a single parents I know
families when my son was growing up
there was a particular boy his parents
had money
and they had two parents
but I remember when he was 16 and he
came around to my house with a son and
he said oh it's his birthday and I said
what is he 16 so where's his cake oh
they just gave him money there is free
money at him and I actually went out and
got him a cake and he gave me a car I
couldn't read away so it could look like
a spider walk through ink you know what
I mean but I see single print I I was
grown I saw loads of single parents they
were worthless and lazy they never put
their child first they don't oh people
always like my son was in hospital my
son's in hospital on his birthday oh
were you worried about no what am I care
about I raised a man not a child he's 37
Mom I'm gonna go and rush around I'm not
that kind of parent I raised a man and a
lot of single parents out there they
don't raise men they raise boys and then
they expect them to be a man I won't
wanna like I always say I'm the
exception to rule I raised a man and
when he didn't get into any trouble to
the age of 21 and then I realized he'd
been in touch with his dad because he's
a piece of crap and it's better to be a
single parent and be positive about it
then to stay in a relationship that is
not good for you and the child not
because you feel it's not good if you
and the child's life is in danger which
hours was but if you know that you have
to lead and if you know that as a woman
you are choosing because a lot of people
choose to be single parents don't choose
to be a lazy single parent equip your
son I always say I raise the man there
is nothing that a child with two parents
could do that my son never done
and growing up when I had one when my
mom grew up and when I grew up and
without a dad
and I was saying that a regular dad I
had a fantastic stepfather he's in my
late stepfather so much so that when he
died I thought why couldn't my dad die
instead of him
it was like the story tale for a black
man to you to sit down and be able to
talk to him and discuss your problems
when I got pregnant I was young I didn't
tell my mum I didn't tell my dad I told
him and I think a lot of single parents
like they're lazy they're lazy if you're
going to be a single parent do something
about it I mean I sent my son to college
to learn life skills
about bills he come up I can't believe
you pay for television license we don't
even watch BBC and I'm like and then do
you know what I mean you have to prepare
them you have to let them know how to do
a tie polish your shoes too many boys
are out there with dirty shoes you can't
turn up and it's true you know a lot of
people don't know how to go and polish a
shoe you will go on an interview and you
see the boy in a pair of jeans a jacket
and a pair of trainers why and you're on
the interview a real man will show a
child how to polish your shoes my son
knew how to spit and polish not know all
these instant wipes no you're gonna put
the Polish on and you're gonna polish it
and you're gonna switch so you can see
your face and go back there and do it
again
and I didn't spoil him I didn't spoil
him
you wanna you wanna eat dinner you learn
how to cut onions if the onions burn
your eye either eat food without onions
or don't eat at all or you're gonna peel
the onions you know he learned how to
ride the bike I've seen like people I
remember volunteering for somewhere and
they had this thing I knew him and there
were children there that couldn't ride a
bike
and I'm like a bicycle you can't ride a
bike and a lot of them are from single
parents
my son could ride a bike he can ride a
motorbike I made sure that everything
that I think a man would teach my son to
do I went and also my man was a great
role model for him
if only his dad would allow and that's
what it is if you're a single parent or
you've got
a woman and she's got a man that you
know that can do better than you don't
be proud about it let him take over
because a lot of people out there saying
oh no I wouldn't have a you know I
wouldn't want a woman with a child or
whatever but
there's someone out there that
everything got the stupid baby father in
the background
to dirty up stuff that they will be able
to get on with it with the woman because
my man was fantastic with my child as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible